crece la presión contra el gobierno de
nicaragua de cara a las elecciones de
noviembre el lunes la coalición nacional
pidió no reconocer los comicios que
denuncia carecen de legitimidad se trata
de un heterogéneo movimiento opositor al
gobierno de daniel ortega así habló para
france24 alexa zamora del partido azul y
blanco perteneciente a la coalición en
este momento no existe ningún espacio de
oposición que tenga garantía de poder
participar en el proceso electoral desde
el oficialismo daniel ortega ha estado
denunciando supuestas injerencias
extranjeras y en respuesta el lunes
rosario murillo vicepresidenta y esposa
de daniel ortega respondió a países de
la región que habían citado a sus
embajadores en managua
citando preocupantes acciones políticas
legales del gobierno de ortega el
gobierno de reconciliación y unidad
nacional informa que ha llamado a
consultas a nuestros representantes
embajadores ante los gobiernos de
argentina colombia méxico costa rica en
reciprocidad ante similares llamados
realizados por los gobiernos antes
mencionados a sus representantes en
nicaragua
pero la presión internacional va más
allá desde eeuu el secretario de estado
a anthony blinken tachó el proceso
electoral de poco creíble y desde la
unión europea
josep borrell aseguró que ortega y
murillo quieren ganar las elecciones sin
competencia
las autoridades nicaragüenses han
detenido a siete candidatos opositores
por supuesta traición a la patria otros
dos candidatos han salido del país y más
de 20 líderes opositores también han
sido apresados mientras daniel ortega
busca su quinto mandato el cuarto de
forma consecutiva